damn good too but you can't be any geek
off the street gotta be handy with the
steel if you know what I'm a nerd you
keep yeah you're like gonna do a
soundcheck we're going I'll say yeah for
sure and then that just mucked up that
whole entire opening today yes okay it's
Friday evening we are gonna get ready
come on
I feel like it's a half-empty house yeah
my name is Ruth they flew me in to play
hip hop they've done that thank you very
much I know very disclaimer I kind of
done it already that is sound and there
is flashing visuals in this talk I will
try and warn you when they do you get
super flashy but yes just if you don't
like it look away leave I won't be I
won't be offended honestly so yes my
name is Ruth this is the part of the
talk where people introduce themselves
they tell you what they've done who they
work for why they should be on stage
teaching you or telling you about a
certain thing except etc I'm gonna show
you that's the easiest way because I'm
here to talk to you about how to be a
web AV artist what exactly right AV by
the way stands for audio vision I'll get
back to to that in a minute
but yeah I struggle with the
practicality of this talk like how many
of you are gonna go back into your jobs
on Monday and just code some AV into
your website or your web app right
I have no better talk anxiety and I came
across this helpful Venn diagram on
Twitter which is also helpful and what
it is it's on the left you've got what
people talk about in conference talks
which isn't so helpful and on the right
you've got what you want to hear in
conference talks which is how
so I've taken this quite literally and
I've made myself two lists okay so on
the Left I've got things that I need to
avoid and on the right I've got things
that I need to include so on the Left
I've got analytics operational
excellence chat opps and orchestration
those are the things that I have to
avoid in this talk to make this a useful
talk but I do have to include duct-tape
workarounds bike shedding and coffee
right okay now my talk anxiety is out
the way we can again by the way I'm
losing a joy Khan this could break at
any time okay so Amy what is an AV
artist a V stands for audio
visualization okay so what we're doing
is we're taking audio and we're making
visualizations from it so it's not so
much of the creating audio as it is
creating visualizations based on the
audio that we have another name for this
is Vijay got control of my audio so this
is pretty loud who remembers this I was
like I'm gonna do that again because I
was like um I got old audio all the way
through this talk please don't turn down
the levels who remembers this oh my
goodness no working is it there is a
sound bite for that I'm gonna try it one
more time one more time audio people
because it's pretty cool we're there now
it really whips the llamas ass thank you
oh can we keep the audio levels up for
the rest of the tour please there is
audio where they do this talk thank you
very much we ramp the greatest mp3
player of all time right for those of
you that don't know when I'm because I'm
of a certain age it basically just plays
mp3 and other audio files when we used
to listen to audio files and not stream
them like we used to own the files we
used to share them via Napster right but
this wasn't the best thing about winner
no no the best thing about winner was
this it had a visualization
engine right so you can play your music
and you'd whip this up and all these
visuals would go in time to the music
and you just sit and watch this for
hours I said this is probably the most
influential thing of any VJ of my
generation um so I was thinking a few
years ago say okay we've got some cool
browser api's now what if I could do
this in a browser good idea I'm gonna
take you to some ways that I have come
to actually be able to do this in a
browser the first thing that we need is
audio right we have a Web Audio API and
there's probably yes it's my favorite
one too
there's sort of four main ways to get
audio with the Web Audio API you can
grab it from the DOM if you've got a
video or an audio element in your Dom
you could just grab the audio from that
and you can push it through the API and
you can stream it from your device if
you've got a camera microphone you can
grab the audio from that and you can
stream it through the API you can go and
get a file you can go and get a sound
file when you get a sound file you do
have to decode it into the API you sort
of got to buffer it in because sound
files by and large are sort of
compressed and you've got to make the
audio api understand the data of the
sound file so we decode it into what we
call a buffer and then we can use that
data you can also create sounds the Web
Audio API so here I'm using an
oscillator to create a sound which is
creating a sound wave you can also use
that but at buffer that I just mentioned
earlier and you can put your own data
into that so you can create things like
white noise quite easily which is just
random numbers and the ones that I'm
sort of interested in either like using
a sound file so this example uses a
sound file
and this one's actually just picking up
on my mic so this one is me it gets very
quiet then it gets really loud yeah the
next thing that we need now that we've
got some sound is we need to analyze
that sound ha ha I wasn't allowed to
talk about analytics it's okay we've got
a whole rest of the tour to go it's fine
we'll be fine
ok ok we need to analyze that sound
because we want to use that data to make
our visualizations that's cool we can do
that with the Web Audio API as well it
has the functionality for you to be able
to analyze any sound that it's in it
right what we're doing here is we're
creating analyzer node a lot of the Web
Audio API is sort of based around this
idea of nodes I'm not going to go into
too much detail about it now but if you
do want to know more about a Web Audio
API come and talk to me later
I would tell you all about it um
somebody wrote some cool stuff on env
and Doc's about it so you can go there
there's some cool demos now and there's
plenty of resources out there and I can
point you in the right direction what
the analyzer node gives us back is an
array of data now that data is the
frequency amplitudes I know right it's
basically it's the low sounds all the
way through to the high sounds and the
sort of volume value of all those sounds
at any given point so the first few
items in the array are going to be the
low sounds and the last few items in
that array are going to be the higher
sounds and the data in that item of the
array is just gonna be the volume value
right and then we can use that to make
our visualizations so here all I've got
is a bunch of elements in the DOM and
I'm just taking those values and
changing the height of those elements
based on what I'm getting back from that
analysis if it's gone yet HTML CSS
really simple took me about two months
so just leaping over those elements and
I'm just changing the height of them now
this is the sort of crux of everything
once you've got that an
is going on you're getting that data
everything becomes a little bit easier
so so I started a whole bunch of
experiments now everything everybody
knows when you start a bunch of
experiments you need some inspiration
this is my inspiration for my first
bunch of experiments this is a super
cool artist Bridget Riley you know she's
a super cool artist cuz it says on the
slide I saw her exhibition and she makes
a new Pacey's huge pictures of shapes
and she experiments herself with these
shapes and I just was walking around I
said oh I've got to try visualizing
these these are really really good so
this is the first one this is just a
whole bunch of sections and they were
just they were all kind of long just set
out with flexbox and I'm just changing
the width of them based on the data that
I'm going back
this one is that triangle CSS border
hack that you've seen and I'm just
changing the opacity of them again based
on that sort of numbers that I'm getting
back from the analysis data when you do
when you start experimenting it gives
you a good opportunity to try any things
this is a couple of years ago and I'm
sort of thinking you know how else can
we expand this and one of the things
that I really wanted to try was some
transforms and getting familiar with
those and I thought wouldn't it be nice
if you could take whatever you have in
there Dom because I'm still working with
just dorm elements and sort of copy it
and rotate and reflect it around the
rest the Dom so you shrink it down and
you just copy copy it around like like
this right so this is only one square
and I'm just running a little JavaScript
function to copy that and then I'm just
reflecting and rotating it around and I
thought hey this is just stuff in the
Dom so um I mean this is my competitive
elements but you know you can drop
anything into the Dom maybe I could just
drop an animated gif into the Dom yeah
you could do that too might look Pony
gifts and we've got so cool like
visualizations and some other lovely CSS
things because I've come to a JavaScript
conference so I thought I'd talk about
CSS that I wanted to try with blend
modes and filters say blend modes if you
are unsure I just you can sort of see
through
like elements underneath in different
ways you can darken you can lighten them
and filters which will become more
apparent a bit later and so you can
invert stuff you can turn things
grayscale you can blur them all really
cool visual things and browser this is a
visualization I did for jazz company you
and I by this point I'm starting to move
over to SVG's so these are all SVG
shapes and you can put blend filter like
blend mode on SVG's and I'm just putting
like a lighting mode on these because it
becomes just a little bit brighter and
it just gives it a little bit more depth
one more sort of CSS thing custom
properties I'm sure we've probably all
seen them we probably are all using them
now and this is the idea of sort of
variables in CSS right so you declare
the variable that you want to use your
custom property you do that in a Dom
element further at the tree so we've got
a dash dash level so as long as you
start it with - - and call it whatever
you want I've got a level here I'm
setting it to a default value and then
I'm using that value under the
property's width and height later on in
my CSS now the thing about custom
property is a really good thing which I
was enjoying is you can update them in
real time right they're not set at
runtime you can you can just update them
in the browser and they will update and
you can do this with JavaScript so in my
JavaScript I can take that analysis
value and pipe it straight into that
custom property and it will update my
CSS for me in real time this JavaScript
all up in your CSS so here I've got like
document.documentelement style set
property and I'm setting - - level with
that analysis level that I'm getting
back so this is an example of me doing
all of those things we've got some Dom
elements they're being rotated and
reflective got some blend modes going on
I'm doing some custom properties and as
you can see it's a little bit janky it
kinda doesn't like operate very well to
talk about operational excellence - cave
- down what this can still go either way
so thinking about the performance of all
of this and this is my friend Ben
if you don't take anything else away
from this talk because I'm talking about
making crazy visualizations in a browser
talk to your friends about things and
not just for rubber ducky
bugs but your actual project because
they might have some other better ideas
so I was chatting to been not allowed to
talk about chops oh my goodness me that
was like - in like two minutes
Oh orchestration I'll make it useful -
so I was talking to Ben
we were team this is this is all going
to the realm of doing something quite
interactive with it
and he made the good point he's sort of
saying well you're doing a lot of stuff
with SVG's you're doing a lot of stuff
with data you're working with the Dom
yet you're kind of doing a lot of maths
have you thought about using d3 now
d3.js being the data visualization
library which back then I was thinking
yeah this is sort of pie charts I'm not
sure some people have done some
incredible stuff with d3 since but yeah
he had a point I'm doing lots of stuff
with data the analysis time getting back
from the audio is data I'm doing a lot
of work with the Dom and it's pretty
good at that it's pretty good at Dom
hoping I'm doing a lot of maths actually
a lot of the positioning things and
working things around and there's some
really nice features of d3 which which
deal with mass pretty well and I just
started working with SVG's and by
default that's how do you three works so
this begins my next set of experiments
this is a book by Tim Lyon called super
graphic it charts data from comics and
graphic novels if you like comics in
graphic novels I highly recommend it
it's really beautiful just a flick
through and so I was peeking through
this and I was like maybe I should try
and visualize some of these this looks
really cool this is a your basic
sunburst chart so again this is all
picking up on my mic so this is just me
speaking and sort of moving around as
I'm talking and I sort of started to
gain momentum this is a really cool of
waynebow this one looks good in a club
this one reimagines the spectrum from
earlier instead of doing lines and
landing circles and they're just going
diagonally across across the screen and
this one which is a little personal
favorite because it's kind of small
sweet it's very similar to the last one
you just got a little flower which is
just going around I'm all pretty it's
gonna stay easy nothing's easy but when
you're using d3 you're just sort of
copying and it's it is making things a
little bit easier
what do you three does is it takes each
item in the array and creates a shape
like an SVG SVG shape per item you get
to define that which is kind of what I
was doing with the Dom it's just I was
doing a little bit more work to do it
and one of the problems with this wasn't
D through and what d3 was doing it was
the data that I was getting back from
the Web Audio API I think the data could
have been better now this is gonna get a
little bit hard to explain and I'm gonna
try it anyway these frequency values
these sounds from low to high they run
from naught Hertz very low to 20,000
Hertz very high right this is what the
human ear hears I'm a little bit older
probably don't hear 20,000 Hertz now but
that's the data that we get back so
that's split up with however many items
that you want to put in that around you
get to define that but one of the issues
that we have with that as music doesn't
run that high music this is a musical
keyboard it probably sits around here on
that scale probably goes around up to
around 8,000 kilohertz so when you're
listening to music and you're analyzing
music there's a hole but there's a whole
bunch of items often this top end of the
array that you just don't need the other
problem when you're analyzing audio like
music audio is this we've got three
notes on this musical keyboard here
they're actually all the same note in
musical terms that will a but they are
all an octave apart so they're all eight
notes twelve semitones part equal spaces
apart and when you play them together
they're very very harmonious that's why
they will have the same letter but some
one low and got in mid one and we've got
a high one now they're equal spaces on
the keyboard but that middle key there
the orange one oh sure you can see the
orange that middle key I've highlighted
that's a middle a that runs at 440 Hertz
the one below it the one that's
highlighted below at the purple one 220
Hertz that's a
of 220 if I can still do maths on a
Friday um the one above it runs at 880
Hertz there's a gap of 440 you see what
happened the gaps doubled so even the
amount even though the amount of Keys
hasn't doubled the amount of frequency
Hertz has doubled so this is a problem
because the analysis that we get back
from the array from Web Audio is linear
and musical notes that really work in
linear so I thought it'd be really nice
if we had better analysis of the Web
Audio API so it chopped off the top of
the array that was pretty simple and
then I spread the rest of the data out
yeah magic function took me about six
months I haven't actually looked at this
for about a year cuz I just wrote it and
I left it's working this is great and
weirdly uh so we're looking at today and
I was just randomly doing some stuff
with WebGL recently I've been doing some
shade of stuff and I'm pretty sure that
there's some algorithms that I'm doing
with that which would actually make this
better
so there is a version of this online
that you can go and have a look at but
I'm hoping that I can refactor it to be
even better soon so that's what this is
doing and then just to prove that it
actually works this is before so we've
got on the right there is where the
shape starts so this is the lower end of
that right and you can say you that it's
there see it's bigger and then this is
after I run the functions
everything's just spread out a little
bit more and we've just got a better
amount of data
what about canvas so at the moment I'm
still using like SPG's and it's still
kind of a little bit heavier if I'm
honest and when I started putting more
items into that array and started
chucking more shapes into the DOM and
but I did start to see a lot more
performance problems d3 really wasn't
necessarily the answer so then I started
to work on 2d canvas which is the one
that you saw at the top of the talk and
this is a lot cleaner it does it like
it's kind of running because I'm running
so many things will happen right now but
when you run this alone this does work
better and I can just chuck so many
shapes and it's brilliant if you want to
see all of these they are on co pen most
of my co-founders audio-visual eyes
so you can see that journey from when we
sort of begin from not being able to do
very much all we have been doing some
canvas visualizations if you're
interested one last bit yeah this is
great we've got some visualizations but
to really be able to sort of bj2 a band
or like to DJ in a club which that would
be cool right I need to be able to
control these now I can probably control
them using the keyboard on my on my
laptop there are some other api's which
are fun like gamepad API is pretty fun
but like if I find it a little flaky
I'm really glad this is holding out it's
still holding out to go a web MIDI API
right we actually are able to run MIDI
in a browser I'm just a little bit about
meeting you just a little rundown and
it's not those beeping noises that you
hear right it is a data protocol so the
instruments can talk to each other it
was it came about because of the rise of
popularity of electronic instruments in
the 70s so in 1983 a group of industry
experts and electric electronic music
manufacturers got together and they put
together a specification you know an
open specification they're pretty cool
so these sort of electronic instruments
could sort of parse out data and they'll
be able to listen to each other this is
a MIDI enabled instrument this is the
musical keyboard we saw earlier and
probably show you for C Mon you're
producing a piano it's very very similar
the thing about this is it it's an
instrument because it has onboard audio
so when you play it you are listening to
sounds but it's also MIDI enabled so it
is passing out those that those data
messages so that it can orchestrate with
other instruments how could I do talk
about audio without talking about
orchestration it's okay I'm hoping that
at least at some point in this talk
you've got something useful out of it
never might so this is what an
instrument is and we talk about music
with MIDI instruments we're talking
about things that onboard audio on and
there's lots of these out there this is
a MIDI controller very similar and you
plug it into your computer you can pick
up on me
data that it's sending and but it
doesn't have any onboard audio this is
what I have with me today it's actually
one of these it's what we call a launch
pad great so basically I can press
button well I can run this code say what
you do in the browser is you you request
access to these many devices there's
lots and lots of MIDI controllers out
there by the way if you want to get
started just google MIDI controllers and
some of them are really really
affordable around sort of 30 bucks I
think from doing dollars and you just
plug it in and you request access to it
and then you can just listen for its
events and all you're getting back is
some data which you can then hook into
and you can do some stuff with so
hopefully if this is working working I'm
pressing buttons on this controller this
is the data that you get back it's just
some numbers and you can listen for
those numbers what they sort of mean is
I am this MIDI controller you're
pressing this button and for those like
there are some where you can press it
harder and you get different funnies you
don't on this one but you know just
pressing buttons I'm going getting
numbers and so this means that I'm going
to go flashing now so be aware this is
gonna get flashy this means I can sort
of easily add effects to these visuals
so we can go back and Y we can change
the colors and go blurry I can do
something vertie
but also it means that in the actual
thing that I use I can change what it is
I'm showing on screen I can actually mix
two visuals together with like you get
like cc's which are like dials so you
can actually mix things together in a
browser there's any of this real like
what are we doing oh like you know
analyzing audio making crazy
visualizations and plugging in boxes of
buttons um this is me with a portable VJ
pack I took a hand bag I put my laptop
in I've got like a mini projector take
one of MIDI controllers and I kind of
hacked the handbag so you can actually
unzip it in a certain way and it like
acts as an usherette tray and you can
just plug the little projector at the
bottom you can just walk around
projecting onto staff which is what I
did this is this is me doing in my in my
streets my city back in the UK and I
write a blog post about this and someone
on the Internet's found the blog post
because the Internet's are cool and they
say
I'm doing this tune I think what are you
doing and actually it's a whole group of
us doing it record low J s we don't just
do visuals there's a couple of people
out there that make software software
that plays music with JavaScript there's
a couple of people out there that
actually control whole lighting rigs
with software that they've built in
JavaScript if you want to check us out
on live Jay s Network we actually we pay
gigs which is slightly insane I think
but it works and we do it and it is
great fun and we talk to each other
about with a crazy technology that we
use and they're great people to talk to
and we also have a github repo so as far
as I'm concerned that must be real it's
the end of the story this was a couple
of years ago since then performance
still was an issue when you've got like
two canvases running because you're
mixing with them and you've got all
these shapes going on you're analyzing
that audio as well I started looking
into workers so web workers have been a
big help that's really helped with
performance
recently I started working with WebGL
which means I could be running
everything on a 3d context instead of a
2d context which means automatically on
a lot of hardware I will be on the GPU
instead of the CPU so that's been pretty
cool I also have been doing some stuff
for this code member because it's
November so if you want to check out
Mike opener as a whole bunch of audio
visualizations based on the genitive
asked artist recom which is a website
that Tim home and put up at the
beginning of this year and it just goes
through if you just want to do some
creative coding here just go through and
do some of his tutorials and just
there's some really nice generative art
tutorials I've got 40 seconds according
to that timer I want to address one last
thing before I go write this see I think
this is useful to look for the keen-eyed
among you you might have noticed the
whole Portofino pack held together with
duct tape
I lost audio again this kind of sucks
and I'm gonna turn it all the way up
okay yeah the poor Pavitra pack code
together with duct tape Ben is on a bike
around and most useful tour ever thank
you very much my name is reto and you
can find me at a tree Maira come and
talk to me after and talk about any of
this
the music in this is by a girl called at
Kanoa she's based in London check her
out on soundcloud thank you very much
[Applause]